hello
good people of the internet i'm dave
rubin
it is december 1st 2020 we are finally
in the 12th and final month of this very
bizarre year
2020. it seems like time has sort of no
meaning anymore like we could be in
december maybe it's june
possibly it's february everything time
has just sort of like
stretched and been pulled and pushed and
thinned out and it's just very very
weird but yes we are in
the last month of the wackiest year at
least since i've been on this planet
since 1976
and we got a whole bunch to talk about
before we do any of that stuff and and
get you caught up on
some of the news of the day today is
giving tuesday
you guys may know about this it's been
going on for the last couple years but
this is often right after
thanksgiving it's the end of the year
people are trying to figure out uh where
they can donate
uh you know some some non-profits that
they can give some money to and help
some charities and things like that
um so i just made a donation and i just
wanted to
remind you guys that there are all sorts
of nonprofits that you can give to
that are hopefully in line with some of
your beliefs
so instead of the government having to
take from you and give to something that
you don't necessarily believe in
if you got a little extra money and you
get a tax write-off and everything else
that there are all sorts of great
non-profits that you can give to
to help education to help animals to
help elderly to help homeless i mean all
of the things that
that we demand the government do you can
often do for yourself so i just made a
donation to animal hope and wellness
foundation
uh which is where we got clyde and let's
throw up
the first picture of clyde uh for those
of you i know most of you know clyde
already but that's the day we got clyde
that was the first day of lockdown
that's at animal hope and wellness and
some of you remember the story emma our
previous dog she was 16 years old she
had cancer she had just died a few
months before
and i was about to go on a book tour we
weren't going to get a dog for about a
year but that first day of lockdown i
heard that all these shelters
were closing and i just ran over there
because they they were saying that they
were gonna have to put all these
dogs down and animal hope and wellness
is not a kill shelter but they had just
rescued clyde from a
kill shelter his name wasn't even clyde
at the time he didn't he didn't even
have a name he had no tags or anything
um but they had just rescued him he had
already they had signed the thing like
he was going to be put down that day
this gorgeous
one-year-old boxer pit mix and we
adopted him
i told david oh yeah we'll foster him
for a week but i knew what was going to
happen
and now we've had him for months and
he's just great and here's a picture of
him from this morning
i mean look at those two pictures right
one he's scared he's nervous you can see
he's got that scar on his head
we had a little surgery we took care of
that and this picture is from uh
from this morning that's uh up on the
roof and we were doing a little morning
meditation
and clyde is good so yes i donated to
animal hope and wellness which is
animal hope and wellness donate but i
hope if you have a couple
couple extra bucks that you will do a
little donating
uh too because there's all sorts of
organizations out there
that line up probably with your beliefs
and
and the things that you want to get done
in society and it's kind of nice
when you can help make it happen instead
of demanding that we just take money
from somebody else
and uh and force people to
to give away their money uh through
taxes instead of just doing it on your
own
okay guys so the three topics that we
are going to discuss today
you're not gonna believe this first one
uh an la counter county supervisor one
of the people
who voted three to two to shut down
all of our businesses basically from
thanksgiving up until christmas until
december 20th and then of course we know
that they'll
extend it into christmas as well and put
these draconian laws and you can't even
have people in your house and
all a series of all sorts of stuff but
literally close down all the restaurants
the only restaurants we have in la right
now are just take out you cannot
even sit outdoors so think about all
these restaurant tours these people
who have built all these makeshift
outdoor things spent more money when
they don't have it because no one's
going to restaurants
now they can't even use that it's
absolutely insane
well you're not going to believe this
one of the ladies who voted three to two
to close down all the restaurants guess
where she went right after the vote
yeah she went out to eat yeah shocking
shocking so we're going to talk about
that then we're going to talk about time
magazine time magazine was once a
respected magazine
when we had sort of respected places of
journalism in the united states it was a
long time ago and for you kids
i know you don't remember it uh but they
have put out their person of the year
nominees
and it includes such incredible lefty
all-stars
like stacey abrams andrew cuomo dr fauci
gretchen whitmer
blm activists and much more so we'll
discuss
that and and then finally i thought this
would be interesting because there's
still
so much going on with the election and
you know i'm trying
not only for you guys but even for
myself not to get totally lost in the
weeds like oh this little thing happened
and that leads to this and
i'm trying to just sort of take in a
whole bunch of information
and and filter it and decipher it in a
way that that makes it understandable to
you guys but also so that i don't get
completely overloaded
well the federalist did a really nice
recap
uh and they did an article called five
more ways joe biden
wait five more ways joe biden out pro
sorry it's called five more ways joe
biden
outperformed election norms and it's
their way of sort of debunking
some of the strange things that have
happened here and and basically
these are the kind of things that you'd
have to believe happened if you
if you believe that joe biden won so so
we'll do
all of that uh before we get to all of
that
though i want to talk to you good people
about billbar
are you looking for a new protein bar
that tastes like a candy bar well
i've got just the one for you it's in my
hand right now i'm pointing to it people
built bars are super tasty and come in
18 amazing flavors as you know i'm a
cookies and cream guy
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
including both nut
and nut free flavors that are soft and
easy to chew with the holidays just
around the corner we're between
thanksgiving and christmas it's easy to
slip up which is why build bars are the
perfect
alternative to pie for the health
conscious guy
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
bill bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein and high fiber
go to biltbar.com and use promo code
ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com and it's good for
bars built go or build boost
and now back to me all right so we'll
start here in la i know
every day some other insane thing
happens here in los
angeles happens in california and not
all of you
watching are from la or from california
god bless you and
good work good smart life decisions for
you guys
um you know people often ask me what am
i doing here like that's the main thing
i get you know i do these shows i talk
about how ridiculous it is and all that
stuff
and people say well what are you doing
there why do you pay the high taxes why
do you deal with the douchey people
you know the lockdowns all that stuff
and the truth is there's really nothing
left here but the weather the weather is
perfect it's
absolutely perfect pretty much all the
time it's like 75
and sunny no humidity every day this
week we're in the middle of the winter
right now so that is
the reason and you know if you if you
live in la you're in some
socal you're in some proximity to the
beach and that kind of stuff it purely
is a
is a weather thing for me at this point
like at some point i guess it was partly
because hollywood was here and i guess
what i do is at least
somehow ancillarily related to
entertainment and hollywood and all that
but the whole business has imploded and
deservingly so so it's not even really
because of that anymore
and a lot of my friends have left i do
know a couple nice people here there's a
couple of refugees we
we bring them in for dinners where they
can speak freely but it's mostly about
the weather but
anyway uh this is just absolutely
incredible
uh i'm gonna give you the quote here
from fox 11 los angeles because
uh just out well we'll just let's just
go to the quote
just hours after los angeles county
supervisor sheila cool
voted for to ban outdoor dining at los
angeles county's
31 thousand restaurants over covet 19
safety concerns
she visited a restaurant in santa monica
where she dined indoors
cool referred to the outdoor dining as a
most
dangerous situation she then dined at al
fresco
she died at al fresco at ilforno hours
after she voted okay so
you understand what these people are
doing so she was one of five people that
voted three of the people voted to put
us in further lockdown destroy the
restaurants
two of them said no she no we're going
to keep them open
she was one of the ones that said yes
but then it wasn't as if you make the
vote and then we locked down at that
moment there's still a couple day window
before all the lockdowns happened so she
then decided yeah we're going to destroy
all the restaurants we're going to lock
everybody down okay
you know and again they never there's no
science that proves any of this makes
any sense or anything like that
but then if it was so dire
lady sheila if it was so dire why would
you then go to an outdoor restaurant now
it turns out she really likes this
restaurant
it's really she's really she really
enjoys italian food apparently
and you know she wanted a little pasta
you know a little penne
a little fusilli and she went out there
and died
but the hypocrisy it's the hypocrisy
more than anything else
if these people behaved in a way that
was consistent with their idiotic
voting records and and
all of the things they say that would be
one thing by the way i would still be
against all the lockdowns and the rest
of it
but that would be one thing but they
want rules for you and not for them that
she knows she knows that it's perfectly
fine to go to a restaurant
but she decides to lock them down and
then she does it herself
i mean try to imagine the gall like
really try to imagine you put this vote
in 31 000 restaurants with
an untold amount of employees and
livelihoods and all that you say i'm
going to further destroy those things
can i get a can i get a pasta let me get
pasta over here
let me get a pen penne pasta please
uh this is this her spokesman said she
loves ilforno
and has been saddened to see it like so
many restaurants suffer from a decline
in revenue
she ate there taking appropriate
precautions and sadly will not
dine there again until our public health
order permit
well she's the one that is doing the
public health order and if
they're the appropriate precautions then
why can't the rest of us do it none of
this makes any sense
these people are authoritarian lunatics
and as you know
i am a freedom extremist and i believe
that people should
be allowed to eat at restaurants if they
so choose
i didn't think when uh 2020 began back
in january 11 months ago that saying
that people should be able to eat
outdoors in los angeles was going to be
a controversial statement
i realized that now it puts you on a
list and i'm probably in a lot of
trouble
um but that's where i'm at people you
should be allowed to eat at restaurants
these people who govern us are complete
morons and
deserve none of our respect or or even
not even respect they don't deserve our
respect and they don't even deserve our
attention
like maybe we just need to start
ignoring them and i mean that at every
level like our police officers should
start
ignoring them like police officers
shouldn't act like the jack boots of the
state showing up at people's houses and
clone
closing restaurants and if you're a
restaurateur open up your restaurant
i saw a story this morning there's some
guy in uh in staten island in new york
who's just opening up his restaurant
he's not charging you can make a
donation
and you know let's see what happens like
are they going to come for him cuomo
probably will
but this is how you fight back it starts
with us guys
okay let's move on to the second story
because you guys know time magazine i'm
sure none of you subscribe to it anymore
i don't know
how many how many people are actually
subscribing to these things anymore
and most places of journalism have
destroyed themselves
trump i mean you know his greatest gift
you know i think he
taught people on the right how to fight
back but his real greatest gift was just
to completely unmask
the the partisan lefty democrat media as
something that is
that is in kahoot with the dems it's
it's it's their pr
agency in effect uh so time magazine you
know they do their person of the year
every year
and their nominees in the political
category this year include stacey abrams
andrew cuomo
dr fauci gretchen whitmore blm activists
and more i'll give you a couple of some
of the other names so fauci 81
said that he should be the man of the
year he's given us all sorts of
uh you know all sorts of very
conflicting and confusing
information on that kamala harris who
polled at basically zero percent in the
democratic primary and then they just
selected her for social justice points
as the vp
she got 68 joe biden broken foot
dementia joe biden got 64.
stacey abrams who's literally never done
anything other than lose a georgia
gubernatorial race
got 59 aoc who's a complete idiot got
38.
cuomo 35 bernie sanders 23 nancy
pelosi 22. whitmer who literally shut
down
uh michigan and told people that they
can't garden at their own houses yeah
she got
19 elizabeth warren got 17 she would
have had 15
but as a native american they gave her
two extra percentage points and then
they did get a couple people
on the right on there donald trump got
eight percent
uh amy coney barrett got six percent
mike pence got three percent
i should also tell you that amy comey
barrett's
six percent that was matched by cardi b
who also got six percent so amy coney
barrett who is now on the supreme court
got six percent and so did cardi b cardi
b of course
uh she's got the the wet ass [ __ ] and
the bucket and the whole thing
and uh that was worth six percent of
support
anyway i mentioned i mentioned all of
this basically
just that these things like these old
structures that existed
the time person of the year this award
the emmys the oscars all of these things
that sort of felt like they
meant something for a long time they
just don't
really mean anything anymore and if
anything
it's not that they don't mean anything
they probably mean the reverse of what
they're supposed to mean right
like the person of the year the person
who
changed the world potentially hopefully
in a positive way now they don't always
do it in a positive way i'm pretty sure
hitler was the person of the year
at one point so it's it's someone who's
just like affecting the world
but this is just more just like
fellating a bunch of lefty politicians
it's just like
boring and no one cares about these
things and and again all
of these institutions i mean the beauty
of it is all of these institutions
journalistic institutions academic
institutions and everything else they're
burning themselves down
in the name of social justice the danger
of course is that it's also coming to
our government i just saw we're going to
cover this story tomorrow but janet
yellen who
is i think biden's nominee for treasury
secretary if i'm not mistaken um she
just gave a speech this morning where
she's talking about how the treasury
will deal
with climate justice and and like just
all of and gender equality
and all of that stuff that it's like we
moved past all of this you guys are
bringing
all of the systemic racism that you're
always talking about you're the ones
that are implementing it in the system
and that's why all of these institutions
they need to collapse if you would have
asked me two years ago do these
institutions need to collapse
i think i was still sort of on the side
of no we've got to fight to keep these
things going
but it's just become obvious that at
virtually every layer they've all become
so corrupt that we have to let them
collapse and then and then we'll see
what happens there
uh so anyway we shall see who becomes
time
magazine's person of the year
you think it might maybe it would have
been that trump guy who had a lot to do
with what was going on this year but
only eight percent for trump but but uh
68
for kamala harris i think the uh the
evil cackling laugh
got her a bonus ten percent uh okay
let's move on to the third story because
i think this is probably the most
most interesting of the day so the
federalists wrote an article called five
more ways joe biden outperformed
election
norm so i want to go through the five
bullet points that they make out there
and
basically what they're saying is there's
a bunch of strange
things that happened in this election by
the way this is exactly
now what uh sydney powell and rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis and the
entire trump team what they're talking
about they're sort of working in two
different ways we know that the sydney
powell side of this thing is working on
the dominion voting machines
and whether they were actually turning
trump votes into biden votes or just
throwing out massive
trump votes and why there were these
very strange spikes at all sorts of
weird hours
that went like 97 percent for biden and
virtually nothing for trump
that's what the palestine and then the
giuliani side is dealing with
late ballots signatures that don't match
duplicate ballots a whole bunch of other
stuff like that
so that's that's all the stuff that
we're going to see go through the courts
over the next couple weeks
but again because cnn and the new york
times and everywhere else
they're not really touching it you've
just got all of these people who
either you're paying attention to it
online and you think that there's
something there or maybe you think that
there's nothing there
but you know it there is something
happening right
or you're just sort of a brainwashed
mainstream media npc
and you don't even know that there's
something going on and imagine if trump
ends up winning imagine if it gets to
the court we find out that there was
massive fraud
that the the dominion voting machines
did things that there were all sorts of
fraudulent ballots in
in pennsylvania and arizona everything
where else well if that happens in a
couple weeks just
if it happens imagine how half of the
country will have no
idea in effect that there was anything
even going on because the mainstream
media
refuses to talk about it that that's why
i'm left
to talk about it i suppose so let's go
through these five bullet points because
there's some interesting stuff here
number one 80 million votes which is
about what trump got
a lot of americans turned out for a
washington politician who's been in
office for nearly 50 years that's of
course joe biden
consider this no incumbent president in
nearly a century and a half
has gained votes in a re-election
campaign and still lost now we know that
trump got probably 11 or 12 million more
votes
than he did last time yet he still lost
very strange
and joe biden got the most amount of
votes all time supposedly even crushing
barack obama seems a little strange okay
what's also strange about joe biden
he's winning despite losing most
bellwether counties
biden is set to become the first
president in 60 years to lose the states
of ohio and florida on his way to
election now that is obviously possible
but it's a little strange for a century
these states have consistently predicted
the national outcome and they've been
considered roughly representative
of the american melting pot as a whole
despite national polling given by an
elite in both states he lost ohio by
eight points
and florida more than three so all right
that doesn't prove
that anything nefarious is going on but
it's just an interesting
point of information number three
biden trailed clinton except in a few in
a select few
cities uh patrick basham a pollster with
an accurate accurate track record
and the director of the democracy
institute in dc
highlighted two observations made by
fellow colleagues
polling guru richard barris of big data
poll and election analyst robert barnes
robert barnes i've had on the show by
the way
barris noted a statistical oddity from
2020's election returns
biden underperformed hillary clinton in
every major metro area around the
country
except for milwaukee detroit atlanta and
philadelphia
that is kind of interesting right that
seems like
something is kind of there wisconsin
michigan georgia pennsylvania
seems every other city that was supposed
to go the way it did
did those were completely out of whack
seems a little odd all right but
again anything's possible number four
biden won despite democrat losses
everywhere else
randy desoto noted in the western
journal that donald trump was pretty
much the only incumbent president in u.s
history to lose his re-election while
his own party gained seats in the house
of representatives
now that's abide a miracle let's unpack
this one for a little bit because
remember we were being told blue wave is
coming the democrats are going to pick
up all these
seats in the house if i'm not mistaken
at this point the republicans have
picked up about 27
seats we can maybe just fact check that
on the flyer i have no doubt that you
guys will check it in the comment
section
but about 27 seats and they didn't lose
any seats so you see it's very odd the
down ticket they did incredibly well but
the incumbent president
who was clearly the national leader with
a 95 approval rating in his own party
he lost but they picked up all the down
ticket stuff it just
seems odd that's all i'm saying just
seems a little odd and number five
biden overcame trump's commanding
primary vote
in the past primary vote totals have
been remarkable
remarkably accurate in predicting
general election winners
political analyst david chapman
highlighted three historical facts
before
election oh you know what i think i'm
missing those
those three historical facts uh all
right
um the point well i know what they are
in essence it all boils down to the fact
that trump did
unbelievably well in the primaries there
was no real reason for anyone to vote
for trump in the primaries right like he
was obviously going to be
the republican nominee there was nobody
running against him in essence
but the numbers that he showed up on top
of if you look at the rallies
and not only the rallies that trump was
at all over the middle of the country
but you saw what it was like when i went
to the beverly hills rally here and
rallies
that were popping up all over in these
car rallies all over the place and
everything else like it all
just feels a little bit a little bit odd
oh okay i've got the
i've got the three uh bullet points here
the chapman highlighted so here we go
first no incumbent who has received 75
of the total primary vote has lost
reelection
second president trump received 94
percent of the primary vote
which is the fourth highest of all time
higher than dwight eisenhower nixon
clinton or obama
in fact trump is the only one of five
incumbents since 1912 to receive more
than 90 percent of the primary vote
so again he did incredibly well in the
primaries and it was about the numbers
that he turned out when he was in
essence voting running against nobody
and finally trump set a record for most
primary votes received by an incumbent
with more than 18 million people turning
out for him in 2020 so that
that gets to that point so anyway look
all of this
all of these things uh are not
proof of anything they are they are not
proof of
fraud they are not proof that votes were
switched
they are strange themes often going back
a hundred years or so
that are at least worth thinking about
and if we don't if we don't discuss any
of these or if
if you bring these things up if you're
immediately dismissed as a conspiracy
theorist
or a kook or a nut bag or whatever it is
or a deplorable
uh then then we've got a real problem
and as i said before
we're seeing right now in some of these
states the fights are still going on
sydney powell is still saying she's got
something and they're trying to move it
through the courts
from day one what have i said and i will
gladly be quoted on this and when all my
haters selectively edit my videos
hopefully they won't selectively edit
this i am not saying
that anything actually happened we have
to go to where the evidence is and at
the end
if they get if it all gets through the
courts and they say well nothing
actually nefarious happened this was
totally legit and so be it joe
joe biden or kamala harris will be
president but if something happened
it is not even if something happened it
is
the duty of the american system to make
sure that people
believe in the system have faith in the
system and how do you do that
well you can audit elections you can
confirm things you can have things go to
the courts and right now we're watching
that system play out and by the way if
you don't think
something's a little odd here kamala
harris has still not stepped down from
the senate right like she's supposed to
be vp in in a mere six weeks why hasn't
she stepped down from the senate that
that does seem a little odd they do seem
like they're getting a little nervous
chuck schumer was on the floor of the
house yesterday demanding that even
before
inauguration meaning before january 20th
that
the uh that the congress should start
voting
on biden's nominees for all of these
different positions it's like
well no why would we do that and of
course he's saying it because of covet
and the emergency and
anyway i think i just think there's more
things happening here
than certainly you're going to see on
mainstream media
okay guys i got a a hectic day
so i'm going to jump but just a reminder
it is
giving tuesday so if you got a couple
extra bucks to spare
there's all sorts of interesting
non-profits just do something that lines
up with your own beliefs
that's it whatever that is if you want
to help veterans help elderly people
animals education whatever it is uh
you know this this is the day to do it
uh and as i said i
donated to animalhopeandwellness.org
which is where we got clyde and they
just do great stuff they actually go if
you go to their site animal health and
wellness dot org
they have pictures of all the animals
that they rescue and usually they rescue
animals
from uh from places like vietnam and
china and things like that
dogs that are going to be eaten and they
often they'll have dogs there that are
missing legs and missing eyes and all
sorts of stuff
and i i go off into the well now you
can't go
because you have to make an appointment
everything else but in normal times i
usually just go there and say hi to the
animals and
there are a lot of good people that work
there uh by the way guys you can watch
part one of my interview
with douglas murray the brilliant dare i
say the brilliant
douglas murray which is up on our
youtube channel
right now that's all if you want to
communicate with me directly
join us at reubenreport.com and i'll see
you tomorrow